on natural basis I'll explain that a
little bit later on but make the heading
now and if I never come back to give you
an explanation then remind me
[Music]
hmm
all right so let's have a crack of this
now quickly to summarize and it's one of
the best easiest things to ever remember
you'll never forget it even after just
spending a day on it
the dreary to the X is just e DX right
so e to the X is this special number
there's two point seven I'm not going to
do it today but later on if you're
curious like why is it that number we'll
come to it but it's a special number
such that if you raise that to the power
of X you differentiate that or pops back
you to your original function but when
you have bases other than that special
number e you get like so close you get
an exponential but it's off by scale it
was like above or below so we multiply
by I think I call it I call it M or in M
M is what I call it because I'm going to
use K for something later so it's like
the exponential you started with not
quite okay now for this reason this base
E is called the natural base right it's
the it's the one where all the
interesting calculus happens and that's
why when you look at logs which we're
going to come to later this week in
exactly the same way we focus on this
base of e it's when you have Ln right
that notation right it means log natural
what's the natural log what's the
natural base to choose for logs and the
answer is well it's a base of e right so
when you have other bases bases that
aren't e this is not official at all
it's just what I call them they're sort
of unnatural you're like what do I do
with this it's awkward how do I fix this
okay so what I want to do right now is
try and find out what the Dickens that
is okay what is that constant at the
front can I find out what it is and not
to say it's a constant that I don't know
about is there some way to actually find
out its value okay so here's what we're
going to do let us try and unpack this
using our knowledge of Exponential's and
logs and you're going to need to think
back to last year when we did this so
let y equal a to the X okay now
this is a problem to deal with to begin
with because I don't I don't know what
this is so I want to try and classic
mathematical problem solving strategy I
want to convert this into a problem that
looks like one I can solve right we've
been doing this all day all year your
entire school career okay so what I want
to do is if I'm not very good at dealing
with unnatural bases let's turn it into
a natural base okay so how do I do that
you need to remember something maybe put
this off on the side okay if you take
log of e to the X log of e to the X we
know that these guys are kind of
opposites of each other
right so if you think about this guy
natural log is going to be with a base
of E and think back to your log laws
what can you do with that power of X
over there you can bring it out the
front it becomes this coefficient right
then you get left with log base E of E
now what is that that's just X okay the
log base a of a is just one okay now
this is taking the log of an exponential
because they're inverse evasions are
inverses of each other
but it's this reason if they're really
like symmetrical inverse I should be
able to do the same thing in the
opposite direction right
instead of taking a log of an
exponential I can take the exponential
of a log okay now if you have a think
about this and I'll let you go back to
where you did this if I said okay let's
make this something like this right how
would you get back to finding out what
this was actually equal to H mmm look at
what we've got on the board all the
knowledge you need all the reminder of
your log laws is there what could you do
how did I get out of here what'd I do I
wrote this as a proper log worked out
words base was right and then I used a
log law okay well I'm gonna the way to
use log words is to put some logs in
here so I'm gonna take the natural log
of both sides
is that okay
log of this log of that do you see where
this is gonna go to see what's going to
happen log of K equals it's in the power
just like it was before what's going to
happen to that power it's gonna come out
the front right cuz that's that's that
this is log X log e I've seen this
before haven't I like 30 seconds ago
yeah log K equals log X so K is X do you
see what I've done so I'm going to take
advantage of that fact over here instead
of writing y equals a to the X I'm going
to write y equals log of M hmm
I'm sorry wrong one I'm doing this one
on the left hand side e to the power of
log that I admit it looks very awkward
and strange why would I do this
and use this some like clearly this is
more complicated messy than this okay
well do you remember what my original
problem was like why couldn't I why was
this a non-starter it's because it has
an unnatural base so what I'm gonna do
is rewrite it in such a way so it does
have a natural base are you with me so
far
okay so far so good for the third time
in like two minutes I'm gonna use a log
law on this see that X in the power I
don't want to write it in power where
else will I put it as the coefficient
over here so this will come to the power
of X log a are you okay with that happy
now I'm pretty much there I wonder if
you could sort of take over from here
I'm gonna rub off everything that's
green but if you want me to rewrite it I
can I can it's just to help us get to
this point really can we differentiate
what we can see here is this in a form
that I can actually work with I think it
is right can I just use chain rule on
this
she's chain rule so if that's why then
dy on DX equals okay what's the inside
function its X log a but don't forget a
is just a number like 2 or 1 point 5 or
10 whatever you put into desmos right so
if a is just the number then the log of
a is also just a number right so what's
the inside derivative if the inside
function was 5x you'd say the inside
derivative is 5 if the inside function
was PI X you'd say that the inside
derivative was PI well this is just log
a times X just like this so the inside
derivative is just long hey yeah what's
the outside derivative it's e ^ blah
blah blah blah right e ^ x log a but
that's awkward isn't it like I only put
it into that form so I could do some
differentiation with it this is what
that really is that's where it came from
you see that you see how all these
right-hand sides are all equal so
therefore this is log a that was the
derivative of the inside and then just a
to the X what you started with okay now
as you can see this is a little bit
confusing here with the brackets and the
A's together so ordinarily this is
written backwards we put that a to the X
out the front as a coefficient and then
you've got a log a hanging out on the
end okay so this solves the mystery of
what the M was over here this what here
we go this is M okay so it's actually
very very simple to use if you
differentiate like that first one that
we started with was 2 to the X right if
a is 2 this is just going to be 2 to the
X log 2
there's the log a-coming goes one of the
tests of a good rule is it works with
everything else that you've used before
right
well this is sort of what we started
with does this still hold true and it
does because if you put into here the
derivative of e to the X using this
longer version of the rule right
you just get e to the X log E but that's
that's just 1 right so that's why it
just disappears and you get the simple
version like we've seen already okay so
when you have a look at question 7 7 I
think it is you'll get all these
unnatural bases and it's just a slight
modification of the rule but if you want
to you can put a big box around this if
you like because this covers now all the
Exponential's you'll ever meet whether
their bases are nice ones or not so nice
any questions